There are a couple of other odds and ends
about the if statement that I want to briefly talk
about. So you know now that the if statement
makes a decision. You go one way or another, depending
on some condition. Now, sometimes, you're code is arranged
so that you don't actually have a decision to do
one thing or another, but the decision is between
one thing and nothing at all. For example, over here,
I've rearranged the code for computing the actual floor a
bit. I'm initializing actual flow with the floor and then
I only need to adjust it if the floor is
greater than 13 and otherwise I need do nothing at
all. In this case, it is perfectly legal to omit
the else part. That's like if you only choose between
doing something or just staying in place. It's okay to
do more than one thing. You could put other actions
inside here, maybe a print statement. Generally in more
complicated situations, there's going to be several statements in between the
braces. Conversely, if there is only one action here, it's
legal to omit the braces. But we won't ever do
that, it's just clear to always put them there.
Makes the code easier to read. Now go ahead and
work out a couple more practice problems with Sarah. And
then we'll talk more about how these conditions are formed.